in high school the student interested in
taking apart and rebuilding machines
approached the CEO of hewlett-packard
and asked for some parts to help him
complete a class project do you lis
impress the CEO made arrangements for
the student to get the parts and tears
later is probably thrilled to be able to
say that he took the time to do so
because that confident students who
asked for the parts
well that was Steve Jobs a man who would
go on to become the CEO of Apple
computers and a preeminent figure in the
tech industry Steve Jobs was born to two
unmarried graduates in 1955 curiously
this is just nine months before
Microsoft founder Bill Gates his parents
gave him up for adoption and Jobs was 30
years old and well in the midst of text
Arden before he learned about his birth
parents Simpsons growing up the only
family he knew was his adoptive parents
a couple from Mountain View California
who fostered his interest in taking
apart and rebuilding machines his father
Paul Jobs was a machinist who taught
jobs about electronics from an early age
working in the family garage the two
spent hours tinkering on projects during
those work sessions in the garage jobs
his father taught him a lesson that has
made its way into Apple's products of
all shapes and sizes don't sacrifice any
part of the design no matter where it is
on the product Jobs later described this
saying when you're a carpenter making a
beautiful chest of drawers you're not
going to use a piece of plywood on the
back even though it faces the wall and
nobody will ever see it you know it's
there so you're going to use a beautiful
piece of wood on the back for you to
sleep well at night the aesthetic the
quality has to be carried all the way
through though Jobs showed an early
interest in mechanics and design he did
not show early promise in school his
mother had taught him to read as a
toddler but he was bored in school and
often goofed off a habit that frustrated
one teacher to the point of bribing him
to behave this teacher saw potential in
a young jobs and jobs later credited
mrs. Hill with being one of the Saints
of his life jobs so excelled in our
fourth grade class with mrs. Hill that
she skipped him over the fifth grade
entirely and he had
straight for middle school this drop the
head though it was pretty tough for him
initially he was bullied and he became a
bit of a loner indeed he disliked middle
school so much that he told his parents
that if he couldn't switch schools he
would just stop going to school
altogether in order to keep jobs in
school he family moved from Mountain
View to Los Altos and jobs settled into
the Cupertino School District it was
here that he met and befriended Bill
Fernandez and other students interested
in electronics Fernandez well he later
played a critical role in the creation
of Apple computers when he introduced
Jobs to his neighbor another electronics
aficionado and someone he might have
heard of his name was Steve Wozniak and
we've actually got more on him
unsurprisingly in a minute by the time
he entered high school well Jobs he was
already working at hewlett-packard where
a cold call to the CEO had earned him a
job offer but while he was in high
school his interests well they began to
diversify a bit Jobs discovered a love
for the classics and for literature in
general Dylan Thomas and Shakespeare
were his particular favorites during a
senior year Jobs was so excelling in
English that he was able to take classes
at Stanford when it came time to attend
though Jobs opted to attend Reid State
in Oregon but well that didn't really
last very long after only one semester
jobs his previous aversion to formal
education reared its head and he dropped
out he continued dropping in on classes
that interested in but he wasn't earning
any credits and he wasn't paying for
anything interestingly one of these
classes that he dropped into what a
greatly affected his future this is
something that he actually explained in
his famous 2005 Stanford commencement
address something by the way which is
well worth watching if I had never
dropped in on that single calligraphy
course in college the Mac would have
never had multiple typefaces or
proportionally spaced fonts
[Music]
despite being a college dropout Jobs was
able to secure a job with Atari
computers in 1974 he worked his attack
assisting the engineers who were doing
the heavy duty coding work jobs didn't
have a lot of money at the time and he
was trying to scrape funds together to
travel to India to study Eastern
religion clearly his interest in things
outside of technology would stuck around
overhead of Atari Neal Bushnell years
later said he thought Jobs might have
been saving money by actually living in
the office I'm not sure about this but I
think Steve was actually living there so
people used to complain that he didn't
smell that well I'd come in on the
weekend and it'd be there I'd come in
late at night and it'd be there the time
this Atari also marked a key point in
the friendship between Jobs and his old
friend Steve Wozniak Jobs was assigned
to designed a circuit board for the
video game breakout and he approached
Wozniak to help because Atari was
offering a bonus if it could be designed
using fewer chips jobs also needed the
project's completers in only four days
what jobs didn't tell Wozniak was that
Atari had offered jobs a large bonus for
using fewer chips a bonus Jobs received
and capture himself even though Wozniak
did the majority of the work when wasn't
Young found out about this like 10 years
later he's reported to have cried but
wasn't young he didn't know of jobs this
deceit at the time and the teeth they
continued experimenting with technology
together but there was a point where
they're tinkering was put on hold
because Jobs is living in the office it
finally saved him enough money to travel
to India he went to India in search of
spiritual enlightenment something that
was rather in the fashion in the 60s and
70s he did this trip on an incredibly
tight budget he slept on the street he
sweated on crowded buses and he ate the
bare minimum he also must have eaten
some pretty sketchy food reportedly
getting dysentery and losing 40 pounds
during this time he was also meditating
and learning about Zen Buddhism he
wanted to go to Tibet but after his
traveler's checks were stolen he decided
to head back home to the United States
when he got back home he continued
meditation as well as another habit had
picked up and that would be the use of
psychedelic drugs jobs he was a big fan
of LSD a drug at shrine in college and
would credit with expanding his
creativity and vision of the world
taking LSD was a profound experience one
of the most important things in my life
LSD shows you there's another side to
the coin and you can't remember it when
it wears off but you know it it
reinforced my sense of what was
important creating great things instead
of making money putting things back into
the stream of history and of human
consciousness as much as I could
[Music]
back in the United States jobs had no
money and lived in his parents toolshed
that he had converted into a bedroom but
he and Wozniak continued to work on
computers with jobs convincing Wozniak
that at least one of Wozniak's early
products was sellable Wozniak had built
a product known as a blue box that could
mimic the tones of a telephone system
and essentially trick a phone into
making a free long-distance call with
technology today we don't really think
twice about calling someone on the other
side of the planet but in the 1970s this
was a big deal now as you might have
guessed yes these blue boxes were
totally illegal but they did still sell
well yeah Steve Jobs his first business
was absolutely selling illegal devices
that allowed you to make long-distance
phone calls for free now the next frame
child that was New York had well it was
much more legitimate it was a product
that would become the Apple one in 1976
job suggested selling it and he and
Wozniak officially started Apple
computers the company was first brand
out of jobs is parents garage and most
of their customers they were hobbyists
well enough computer hobbyists were
laying out money for the Apple one that
jobs in Wozniak
well they had cash in their pockets jobs
began searching for investors and
Wozniak he kept designing in 1977 which
was just one year after the company
launched they put out a new version of
their computer called the Apple 2 this
time it had color graphics and was much
more user friendly allowing it to be
used outside of just the hobbyist market
they sold 8 million dollars of the Apple
2 in their first year alone but this
figure I was about to become dwarfed 2
years later they had sold 200 million
dollars worth but again this seemingly
huge number was about to be dwarfed yet
again in 1980 only four years after
their launch jobs and Wozniak they went
public by the end of Apple's first day
of public trading the company was worth
an astounding 1.2 billion dollars Steve
Jobs it was only 25 years old
[Music]
during the nascent years of Apple Jobs
was dealing with much personal turmoil
his longtime on-again off-again
girlfriend Hasan Brennan had moved in
with him and while she got pregnant
jobless was by all accounts not really
thrilled about this news he later told
Brennan I never wanted to ask that you
get an abortion I just didn't want to do
that Brennan had been offered a job at
Apple but given jobs his reaction to her
pregnancy she did not want to take it
she left him and their house and began
working as a cleaner
despite asking for support from jobs he
did not provide any support for his
child until a paternity test confirmed
that he was the father even then despite
his company being worth over a billion
dollars he was only required to provide
$500 a month in child support despite
these early problems Lisa and jobs they
eventually reconciled and Lisa even
lived with jobs during her high school
years she then attended Harvard and
today she works as a writer in New York
City though it took him years to admit
jobs actually named one of Apple's early
products after his daughter but at least
a computer it wasn't as successful as
the Apple two had been this failure it
was followed by another the Apple 3
which again failed to live up to
expectations and it's not just jobs as
expectations but everyone's despite
Apple being Joneses company the fact
that it was public meant that the Apple
board had the power to oust him as CEO
and while they did just that in 1983
they didn't really fire him though they
just sent him to Siberia and not
literally Siberia of course but the
office he went to was referred to as
Siberia because it was so out of the way
that it was basically exile now most
Apple employees they were probably
pleased to see him go he was notoriously
difficult to deal with and a former
Apple employee described jobs as
attitude toward work as management by
character assassination by in 1985 while
he was tired of hanging out in Siberia
and decided to leave the company that he
had found it and start a brand new one
what had been the focus of my entire
adult life was gone and it was
devastating job set of the sixth
I even thought about running away from
the valley but something slowly began to
dawn on me I still loved what I did and
so I decided to start over
they started next computer company which
brought its first product to market in
1988 that computer though it's at a
price tag of $10,000 a price way higher
than most consumers were willing to pay
needless to say it did not sell well
this wasn't a good start for jobs this
fledgling company and so he decided to
shift the company into building software
[Music]
but Jobs is focused while it was drawn
elsewhere towards something rather
unusual for him it was the movies in
1986 he bought Pixar from George Lucas
as part of his dream for this company
Jabba's wanted to be responsible for the
first movie done entirely with computer
animation it took four years but
eventually he achieved that dream well
that movie there was Toy Story it was
released in November of 1995 and it
became a favorite film for both kids and
adults to this day it maintains a
perfect 100% score on Rotten Tomatoes a
year after the release of Toy Story
there was even better news jobs took a
Pixar public and in something of a deja
vu situation his shares were worth 1
billion dollars after the first day of
trading the first day of trading well it
was the first in a string of good days
for jobs shortly after Pixar went public
Apple put out the welcoming mat for
Steve Jobs to return when he returned to
Apple in 1997 the company it was
operating at a loss and they needed jobs
his vision and drive back at the helm
apple also announced that they would buy
the struggling next computer company
turning a previous failure of jobs into
a success Jobs he triumphantly returned
to the company that he had found it the
company wanted him to bring Apple to the
forefront of the personal computer
market within months of his return jobs
he was named CEO he paid himself a
salary of only $1 a year and in exchange
brought both business acumen and
creative design ideas
the company he negotiated a financial
deal with Microsoft that brought Apple
the cash flow that it needed to stay
afloat while also helping Microsoft
avoid the perception that they were a
monopoly then he envisioned the big idea
that helped bring Apple back to
profitability in its own right and that
was the iMac he was in 1998 that Apple
released the brightly colored egg-shaped
desktop computer called the iMac the I
leg is even still made today although it
looks rather different from the iMac
forward to Kaplan jobs they just gonna
miss they revolutionized the way people
listen to music in 2001 with the iPod
and then the way they communicated in
2007 with the iPhone and then they were
pioneers in the tablet market with the
2010 release of the iPad jobs weren't
said of Apple I started out to get a
computer in the hands of everyday people
and we succeeded beyond our wildest
dreams
today well it's nearly impossible to
walk down the street without seeing
someone with an Apple made device in
their hands and through all these years
of professional success Jobs still found
the time to focus on his family in 1986
his adoptive mother was diagnosed with
lung cancer and this first time prompted
Jobs his interest in his biological
parents when his adoptive mother passed
away Jobs spoke to his father about
contacting his birth parents whose names
he had on documents from his parents
javis mares both his birth mother Joanna
Scheible and his biological sister Mona
Simpson shortly after his adoptive
mother died schaible then Jobs his birth
father had divorced in 1962 when the
Syrian migrants opted to return to Syria
after earning his PhD when Jobs was
introduced to Mona she was still
searching for their father Jobs joins
her in the search and what they found
out when it was quite surprising
the father well he was not in Syria
working in academia rather their father
was living in California and running
restaurants incredibly job said he had
met the man Mona identified as their
father had even shaken his hands and
eaten in his restaurants but he'd never
known he was his father jobs though he
had no interest in getting to know his
father as had gotten to know his mother
and Mona explaining his decision by
saying it lends a little bit about him
and I didn't like what I learned while
guessing's knew his birth family jobs
also decided to start a family of his
own
in 1989 Jobs gave a lecture at Stanford
Business School and he was riveted by a
woman in the front row she was right
there in the front row in the lecture
hall and I couldn't take my eyes off her
kept losing my train of thought and
started feeling a little giddy this is
the feeling that jobs described when he
first met Laurene Powell read Powell was
an MBA student at Stanford and jobs
struck up a conversation with her after
the lecture he invited her out to dinner
that night and the two they began a
romantic relationship the Zen Buddhist
monk presided over their wedding
ceremony at Yosemite National Park in
1991 and over the next seven years the
couple had three children they remained
married until Jobs's death amid all of
these successes of the early years of
the 21st century Jobs was not free from
worry and well neither was Apple
computers in 2003 Jobs received the news
all of us dret she had cancer his
doctors have found a cancerous tumor in
his pancreas and though operable it was
a rare form of cancer
well jobs he refused to listen to his
daughters and have an operation right
away instead he opted to explore other
options namely veganism and acupuncture
in 2004 with these alternative methods
not improving his condition Jobs opted
to have the tumor surgically removed
several cancer specialists have since
said that that period of waiting may
have cost drops years of his life in
2005 Jobs gave a commencement address at
Stanford University that frankly and
poignant Lee discussed his thoughts on
life and death now that he had to
confront the matter head-on the fifteen
minute speech reflected on three moments
in his life that helped him get to where
he was and been telling those stories he
imparted a message the graduates span to
the world to do what you love remember
you are going to die and to trust your
inner voice remembering that I'll be
dead soon is the most important tool
I've ever encountered to help me make
the big choices in life because almost
everything all external expectations all
pride all fear of embarrassment or
failure these things just fall away in
the face of death leaving only what is
truly important remembering that you are
going to die is the best way I know to
avoid the trap of thinking you have
something to lose you are already naked
there is no reason not to follow your
heart he closed the speech with simple
words from the
1970s countercultural magazine the Whole
Earth Catalog stay hungry stay foolish
the commencement address struck a chord
around the world has been viewed over 27
million times on YouTube and serves as
an inspiration and a stark reminder of
our limited time on earth it was a
speech that truly every human can relate
to given by a man whose mind and drive
were far more extraordinary than most
humans jobs continue to work at Apple
following the surgery but in 2008 people
began asking questions about his health
as his appearance began to show his
illness he was gaunt graying and just
didn't seem healthy the company
continued to explain this away after
questions were raised at one tech event
Apple attributed his appearance to a
simple bug and said he was taking
antibiotics shareholders they continued
to worry and in 2009 the truth came out
Jobs was suffering from ill health and
ended up having a liver transplant Tim
Cook Apple's head of worldwide sales
filled in a CEO while Jobs was
recovering from the procedure Jobs later
managed to return to his post and
continued to be involved in the
day-to-day operations of Apple with his
prognosis being described as excellent
but unfortunately this was not to be
only a year and a half after returning
to the helm of Apple Jobs had to step
down a CEO in providing his reasons to
the company board he stated I've always
said if there ever came a day when I
could no longer meet my duties and
expectations as Apple CEO I would be the
first to let you know unfortunately that
day has come
though he stepped down as CEO intended
Tim Cook the reins of the company Jobs
did serve as chairman of the Apple board
sadly it was only for six weeks that he
would work for Apple in this capacity on
the 4th of October 2011 jobs lost
consciousness he stayed at home
surrounded by his family and died of
complications from his pancreatic cancer
on October the 5th he was only 56 years
old the world greeted the death of this
technology icon with shock and grief
California's governor issued a
proclamation for a Steve Jobs day to be
celebrated and the companies with which
he was associated issued statements
about the life creativity and innovation
of their founder and partner his family
held a private funeral
the details of which are still unknown
in 56 years of life and 30 years in the
tech industry Steve Jobs was at the helm
of guiding the world into the future he
was certainly a difficult man to deal
with but he was an innovator a
businessman and a visionary whose ideas
shaped the world in which we live today
so I really hope you enjoyed their
biography of Steve Jobs if you did
please do subscribe to our channel we
put out brand-new biographies just like
this every Monday and every Thursday so
subscribe for more also check out some
of our other biographies over there on
the right if you like this you probably
like those long-form looks into people's
life check them out there they're worth
watching loads more on the channel
itself and as always I'll see you in the
next video